[Music]
we have a little segment on the podcast
we call more about less we read
something as a jump off point sometimes
it's an article or a tweet so i brought
in
this article from
scarymommy.com my favorite dating site
hey i'm going to get a gk chesterton
quote in before we before you quote
eckhart tolle um so we can keep our
priorities in order but anyway this is
perfect because we're all pronouncing
his name three different ways we think
it's eckhart tolle right i thought i
thought about solely
okay then on the odd man out i said
should verify no but i say
so okay
thankfully there is no right or wrong so
we're good
the gk quote and this captures kind of
where i stand on like the the beliefs
the opinions the good bad he says the
purpose of an open mind is that of an
open mouth and it is to chew up on
something solid an old philosophy
professor of mine timothy mcgrew he used
to always say
keep an act of mind rather than a
passive mind and i tend to like that a
little bit better than open or closed
because
i'm not open to everything yep and i'm
not close to everything but i choose to
be active about it all i choose to think
critically and creatively about it all
but at the end of the day i want to
close my mouth and my mind on something
substantial and chew on it yeah you
don't want it to be porous so let me get
to this article here i'm just going to
read a few of them and maybe we can
agree or we can disagree on them i'd
like that too so this is a hundred plus
eckhart tolle
tolle
toll quotes that will seriously
enlighten you which is a bit uh a bit
hyperbolic there i'm not going to read
the whole article we'll put a link to it
in the show notes but here are a few of
the quotes we'll start with the first
one here the past has no power over the
present
well tk you and i often say
you talked to me about this you've never
said it on the podcast but how any of
these little minimal maxims these little
profundities these bromides that we toss
about they can be simultaneously true
and radically untrue at the same time
yeah i believe that every statement no
matter how much you love it no matter
how logical it is can be made to sound
absolutely ridiculous if you easily
interpret it in a certain way one day we
should do a test where i can prove this
you give me any statement and i can show
you how someone can interpret that in a
way that makes it sound ridiculous let's
do it right now
is just put it on twitter and 20 people
will show you
all right so the past
has no power over the present moment
well in everyday practical life that's
certainly not true yeah because we stay
stuck in the past now of course the past
exists only in the present moment
because there is no past in that respect
and i'm sure that's what he means so
right that's we have to get curious
right what does he mean
because if i went up to eckhart tolle i
was like well that's stupid because i i
have a cousin who's still living in the
past today is eckhart tolle gonna go oh
bro you blew my mind
i never thought about that he'll
probably say yeah i know people too who
are in some meaningful sense stuck in
the past but let's go a little bit
deeper rousseau here's another one for
you some changes look negative on the
surface but you will soon realize that
space is being created in your life for
something new to emerge well that seems
like a a bit on the uh
a new take on that chinese farmer
parable in a way yeah sometimes the
worst things happen to us the worst
suffering sure ends up being the thing
we're most grateful for yeah that's
that's i like that quote it's a good
quote
so no discipline seems uh
enjoyable in the moment but then it
leads to a harvest that is a new
testamental testament i think that's in
um i think that's some proverbs yeah so
yeah that's
he's copying the
bible let's jump around here so
uh let's see sometimes letting things go
is an act of far greater power than
defending or hanging on
well as the minimalist is not the only
one that thinks these are just like all
super fake deep quotes like the skin is
the skin until the skin leaves its body
and then it is no longer one with the
skin
so i'll play angel's advocate with that
real quick we call those faux funded
ease where someone's both funded
i'm gonna use that it sounds profound at
first and then you listen again and
you're like whoa you just
that doesn't make any sense
uh my daughter makes these up all the
time she has a great twitter account we
should it's not her account but we just
like tweet the craziest [ __ ] that she
says
and uh yeah and and she's full of faux
fun that is she looked at me uh earlier
this year and she goes is the 4th of
july on the 4th of july this year
so
angel's advocate first a faux fungi
is something that actually has no
meaning you're pretending to be saying
something it has no meaning that's not
the the concern or criticism here and i
hear this comes up a lot which is why i
want to play angel's advocate the
concern here is like okay
i get what the brother's saying
but does it even need to be said right
it's like so basic and so obvious
i get that
but i also work with elementary school
students and high school students and
one of the things they have taught me
and they continue to teach me is that
obviousness
is relative to the hearer right because
when when we listen to something we go
okay does that even need to be said
we're bringing a whole lot of life
experience and a whole lot of
accumulated wisdom into the moment and
so when someone says hey man sometimes
working hard is a good thing it sounds
laughably obvious but believe it or not
just like there are people every year
who are born who need to be taught how
to pronounce the words of the alphabet
there are thousands of people out there
millions of people who will hear that
for the first time today and they'll go
wow that's really profound and some
people will hear it just because it came
from you or just because it came from
their brother and so we can never say
the obvious truths too much because as
angry as someone will get on twitter for
you daring to say something that they
already knew god forbid there are always
people out there who don't know it and
who need to hear it from you so i am a
defender of stating obvious truths to
every generation because there are
people born every day for whom those
truths aren't obvious if it's true
say it i love that let me just let me
just add something to this and this is
this may be controversial and yeah
you're you guys may not like me for this
but
i think
the deeper issue in my opinion is that
there's the spectrum between
post-modernism where there is no
objective reality and everything is your
truth versus my truth and your reality
and then there's the other end of the
spectrum of like radical fundamentalism
from a religious mindset and i think
i would say jesus and the scriptures are
going to lean more towards hey there's
objective reality there's absolute truth
there's morals there's right and wrong
and i think the issue with someone like
like an eckhart tolle is that he's
taking ancient truths that we've known
like you said the thing i was like oh
yeah that's a proverb right
and and it's being repackaged to a
post-modern world where people don't
want objective prescriptions they don't
want objective realities they don't want
to be told what is right and wrong they
want to live their truth in their
reality and i think that to me is the
deeper underlying issue of why he's even
so popular of how kendrick goes from i'm
baptized i'm going to church i'm trying
to marry my my kid's mother to
faux realities what would you call them
go fun to do full funded ease
i'm going to kind of weasel my way out
of whatever i don't really feel like
doing in the moment because it's not
conducive to how i feel about my reality
and so again i don't mean to get super
controversial but this super duper
post-modern you are your truth whatever
you feel is real
flesh that out to its logical conclusion
and some of the stuff that's happening
in society right now and there's some
wonky stuff happening
based on this
whatever you whatever floats your boat
bro just do you and your truth and so i
think that's the the deeper issue with
the new ageism and why why is eckhart
all of a sudden an authority oh it's
because people really don't want to deal
with some of the objective ancient
truths we've had all along in my opinion
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free